>>> OKAY NOW, SMILE.
OH MY GOSH, YOU TWO ARE SO CUTE.
AND I GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT, NOW, I WANT TO DO ONE
LONG WAVE.
>> MOM, COME ON.
WE'RE GOING TO BE LATE.
>> ELIZABETH, CALM DOWN, PLEASE.
I JUST WANT ONE MORE.
>> OH WAIT, I GOT AN IDEA.
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> WHAT, GRANT?
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> I GOT AN IDEA FOR THE
PICTURE.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
HOLD ON.
>> SORRY, SHAWN.
MY PARENTS ARE BEING SO LAME.
>> IT'S OKAY, BABE.
WE GOT TIME.
MRS. SANDERS, TAKE AS MANY AS
YOU WANT.
>> SHAWN, I KNEW I LIKED YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NOW, SCOOTCH TOGETHER
AND SMILE.
OKAY, 1.
2.
>> WHOAH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> DAD!
>> WHAT?
I SAW IT ON THE INTERNET.
IT'S FUNNY.
>> CHRIS, I TOLD YOU WHEN WE'RE
-- WE WEREN'T DOING THIS.
>> OH COME ON, IT'S FUNNY.
>> DAD, HOW IS IT FUNNY?
>> OH YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE "HEY,
MISTER, YOU BETTER NOT TRY
ANYTHING, I'LL SHOOT YOU."
PEOPLE ARE DOING IT.
IT'S A THING.
AND I WAS LIKE, "BANG!"
>> DAD!
>> STOP!
>> OH, COME ON.
RELAX.
[ BANG ]
♪♪♪
>> OKAY.
WHAT HAVE WE GOT?
>> MALE, AGE 48.
BLEW HIS [ BLEEP ] TAKING A
PHOTO WITH HIS DAUGHTER.
>> ANOTHER PROM PICTURE?
>> YEP.
♪♪♪
>> CHRIS, WE'RE RIGHT HERE.
>> DID YOU GET IT?
>> I TRIED, HONEY, BUT IT'S
PRETTY ROUGH.
>> YOU GOT TO MOVE.
>> YEAH.
>> IT FITS.
>> IS IT ALL RIGHT?
>> OKAY MR. SANDERS IT LOOKS
LIKE WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
REATTACH.
>> OKAY, YOU CAN PROBABLY JUST
DO IT, THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> NO, SIR, I DO NOT THINK WE
CAN DO THAT.
>> YOU CAN PROBABLY REATTACH IT
THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> NO, SIR, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
POSSIBLE.
>> BUT YOU CAN JUST DO IT,
THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> NO, SIR, WE CAN'T.
>> OH GOD!
>> IS MY DAD GOING TO BE OKAY?
>> I'LL DO WHAT I CAN.
>> MY GOD, CHRIS, HOW COULD YOU
BE SO STUPID?
>> I WANTED TO TAKE A FUNNY
PICTURE.
>> WHAT IS FUNNY ABOUT HOLDING A
GUN AROUND KIDS?
>> 'CAUSE I DON'T WANT THEM TO
HAVE SEX.
>> THEY'VE BEEN DATING FOR THREE
YEARS.
THEY'VE HAD SEX!
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH, DAD, WE'VE DONE IT A
LOT.
>> WHEN?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHEN WE ALL
WENT TO JAMAICA AND YOU DIDN'T
SEE US THE ENTIRE TRIP?
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, THEN.
>> YEAH, AND DO YOU REMEMBER ALL
THOSE TIMES THAT YOU WAKE UP AND
I'M IN THE KITCHEN SHIRTLESS
DRINKING A GATORADE?
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, THOSE TIMES TOO.
>> OH, WHY?
>> OKAY, MR. SANDERS, WE'RE
GOING INTO OPERATION.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT YOU
UNDER, ALL RIGHT?
>> WAIT, WAIT.
LINDSEY I'M SORRY I RUINED YOUR
PROM BY BLOWING MY [ BLEEP ] OFF
WITH MY GUN.
LAURA, I'M SORRY I DIDN'T LISTEN
TO YOU AND SO I BLEW MY LITTLE
[ BLEEP ] OFF WITH MY BIG OLD
GUN.
>> IT'S FINE.
>> AND SHAWN, YOU'RE LIKE A SON
TO ME.
YOU TAKE GOOD CARE OF MY
DAUGHTER.
>> THANKS, MR. SANDERS.
>> BUT TONIGHT, OUT OF RESPECT
TO ME, PLEASE DON'T HAVE SEX
WITH EACH OTHER.
>> WE WILL, BUT YEAH.
>> DON'T.
>> WE'RE GOING TO, BUT OKAY.
>> NOT TONIGHT OUT OF RESPECT
FOR MY CONDITION.
PLEASE DON'T.
>> YES, SIR.
WE WILL, THOUGH.
>> NO, FOR ME, JUST TONIGHT,
DON'T.
>> YOU GOT IT, DAD.
WE ARE.
>> I'M SAYING DON'T DO IT.
>> YOU GOT IT.
>> YEAH, WE ARE, THOUGH.
>> I BLEW MY [ BLEEP ] OFF
TONIGHT.
PLEASE DON'T HAVE SEX.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]